do you think uh we should defund the
police i think i've said no already i
think you asked me that
did i no uh i think i said there are
some uh
so right now there's like tons of cops
in public schools yeah yeah yeah very
needlessly some maybe occasionally
schools need a cop
but right now i think like half of all
high schools have a police officer in
them
if you went back to 1970 there would not
be a single police officer in any school
in america just didn't happen
now they're there and all the
disciplinary problems between students
default to them so you have cops called
on you know kids rough housing now it's
going to be an assault charge
it's going to be it's going to be on
their record um it
really it's terrible for kids i feel so
bad for them but didn't they have gun
like i don't know about the 70s but i
hear these stories about how like way
back when people would bring their gun
with them to school
yeah you had rifle clubs yeah clubs that
kind of thing yeah it was a
it was a better time i mean no now
there's a freak out about guns in
schools that is
like vastly disproportionate to the
danger of guns in schools i mean they're
that we just we freak out about school
shootings to a degree that is
insane when did they ban guns from
schools
um i don't know when precisely they
banned guns from schools they started
putting because of the
cops so there were federal grants to
schools to hire more cops
and then there was more zero tolerance
programs that if you have a gun in
school
yeah you're going to be expelled
immediately or anything that looks like
a gun or even like a piece of a piece of
plato you shaped into a gun in some way
this store by that kid who was eating a
pop-tart yeah yeah yeah i've written
i've
written about that kid so for the people
who don't know
some kid was eating a pop-tart and he
bit it into the shape of a gun
yeah and i guess he was holding it like
a gun or something i mean i a kid got
suspended for like
wearing the magic lord of the rings ring
and saying i make you disappear like
schools are
so paranoid about violence well now it's
and now it's zoom class
i wrote about this this week well we
actually we actually have okay yeah
let's pull this up this was insane think
about creepy dude this is from yesterday
yeah this and so this happened a couple
times this was a kid who's playing with
it briefly with a nerf gun clearly a
nerf gun it's a zombie hunter
during virtual class zombie and
the school the teacher notices it and
the school decides
to call the police the police show up to
this kid's house
to make sure you know he's safe and well
this is kind of the merging of child
services and law enforcement and
education
that unfortunately zoom learning
distance learning really permits
um and he would he they suspended him
for five days he's never going back to
that school anyway his parents said this
is ridiculous good
good good i know yeah they said charter
school or private school for us
yes yes um this is so this is a concern
i have about distance learning
one of many is that it invites the state
into right into your house right into
your house i mean massachusetts
department of
families their child services equivalent
gave out some guidance to teachers
saying
you know make sure while you can see on
the screen you know does the child look
like they're unhappy or emotionally
unwell which is probably every child in
america right now because it's a
terrible time
yeah but if they look like they're
malnourished or they skip breakfast you
might want to
alert us child services and we'll do a
check which is not good because
again inviting the police to come into
the house
people get upset people act irrationally
uh people get arrested for things and uh
and it's just this strain
on on the least able parents the parents
who have the most kind of stress in
their lives the working class
family um it's terrible what do you
think this is gonna do to these kids
when they're older
i mean i think they're going to go and
they're going to be they're going to be
nuts
it's it's tough to predict this this is
a harmful year for kids certainly
what was it was their emotional
development their intellectual
development
did michael malus he said that they were
prisons for kids
i don't recall that was that michael
that's something he believes i think
yeah
i've chatted with him he was calling
schools prisons for kids
yeah basically saying that it's it's you
know they
the teachers are bullies they're forced
to go there they're locked in they hate
being there
everyone's unhappy yeah i think schools
are trash
and they're only getting worse right so
that's the important point they've
gotten more prison like
right certainly over the last 30 years
um
in terms of what you and it can ruin
your life to get in trouble for
something these days i mean it can ruin
your life
to find out you know you tweeted you
know when you were 14
something like homophobic or or or
racist
or even a joke or a joke um i feel so
bad for kids these days i mean i so i
finished my adolescence
immediately prior to the era where there
are now smartphones everywhere and
everything everyone says is being
recorded
and and there's video of you at all
which is good
i feel terrible for these kids but every
their every mistake they've made
um is is out is out there the purpose to
me of school
is is partly to socialize young people
and get them and get them
so when they make mistakes they're
forgiven and then it's over then it's
forgotten
nothing's forgotten now i i think so i'm
i'm very very pro homeschooling
and i've heard a lot of people say what
about
socializing the kids i completely
disagree with this
i don't think kids should be learning
from other kids i think kids should be
learning from
working people in normal society so
that's my experience when i was growing
up i
my family had a business and i did
interact with other kids my age but i
also would work on the weekends at my
family business strictly interacting
with adults
on normal adult-like things so the way i
view it is
what's going to actually teach a kid to
function in the real world
being around a bunch of kids who are
talking about dumb things that don't
understand
or hearing adults talk about normal
adult things business management and
politics and
you know just general life stuff oh i
gotta pay the mortgage what's the
mortgage well the mortgage is like this
you go to school and what do you do they
they open up the book they teach you the
same thing over and over again every
year
like that's the craziest thing about
public schools to me is how many how
often they just regurgitate the exact
same lessons over and over again
and then when you're actually
interacting with people it's people who
don't know how the world works
and you're spending what you know 18
19 years or maybe even until you're 24.
uh well you know 18 19 years and
you know because you're five when you
start kindergarten and you've not
interacted with adults
other than being berated talked down to
and treated not like an equal so you get
a lot of people who are just
actually this is an interesting point i
think one of the reasons why we're
seeing
right now are politicians uh trump is
what 74 and biden 77 and bernie is
what 78 right they're all really old
very old and i think it's because of the
way our school systems are functioning
and creating people who only know how to
look
up to the older you know uh generation
to be told what to do
i think it's a product of what our
schools are doing so anyway the point is
i wasn't reading that up
when you take a look at these stories
like a kid's playing with a nerf gun and
now they're in his home
and now these these these policies that
were kind of oppressive to kids are now
coming into their own private spaces
it's going to get a whole lot worse i
mean you think the sjw college crisis is
bad now and these people are out in
public
amplify that tenfold well i think it has
to teach
it encourages young people to view
themselves as victims that's how you get
ahead
is to say you're victimized by something
or also to crave a kind of safety that
is ridiculous
um or and also to think that the purpose
of the authority figures in the society
is to provide you
comfort and safety and protection from i
mean
in the schools we're talking about
imaginary threats like school is a very
safe place for kids
yeah kids are safer in school than they
are
outside of school in virtually every
place in america um it's just not but we
we act like they're like they're they're
war zones
um with all the policies we put in place
to keep kids safe and and like
like like perfectly coddled all the time
and i i have to think that's an
unhealthy educational environment
definitely did you hear about what
happened in chicago
with that kid put in the padded room no
what happened there was some kid was
acting out
and the chicago school has a
locked padded room where the kids who
are acting up just get put inside they
close it it's terrible
and that's like like solitary
confinement for kids
yeah so apparently the kid was like
freaking out and then he like crapped
his pants and he was covered in feces
and then started crying
saying he was sorry and begging for help
and they just left them there
solitary confinement is really terrible
torture it's awful for hard and criminal
adults who deserve to be in prison it's
still awful for them i can't imagine
doing that to kids could you imagine
like
you've seen the movie castaway right yep
inflicting the wilson
wilson on a kid like the desperate their
desperation for some kind of human
interaction
it's worse for kids though i mean if
you're an adult
at least you've actually had time to to
grow up and kind of harden yourself to
some degree
these kids are scared fragile don't know
what they're supposed to be doing
and if they're they're being treated
like adults in the wrong way yeah it's
like you do something wrong you're an
adult
if you're if you're inquisitive we're
gonna treat you like a [ __ ] yes
so i i hate school man i don't know i
don't know what your thoughts are on
homeschool though
i'm in favor i mean i'm in favor look
i'm in favor of families making
whatever the right schooling decision is
for their individual kid
because it is different for every kid
some kids will thrive in a traditional
educational environment
some ski some kids will thrive in
something else i think
you you your family should be able to
decide what that is the money that is
being spent by the government to educate
your your kid
maybe you should have some control on
how that's spent instead of just
automatically going to this very
libertarian of you
yeah so what do you think about school
choice like the or like the voucher
program specifically yeah so that's
that's basically the implementation of
that philosophy which is that the dollar
should follow the student
rather than just going to the school i
mean some of these school districts
spend an obscene amount of money per kit
we're talking
10 10 or 20 or 30 thousand dollars per
kid wow
and to have terrible educational
outcomes like you'd think with that much
money per kid you
you could achieve something and they
don't and they fail because and this
isn't even like this is a moderate
this isn't even saying we shouldn't like
fund education we're just saying like
maybe the government
sure you can fund education but maybe
the government is not the best at
actually doing the educating so maybe
they haven't quite figured that out yet
and we should like leave that to the
professionals
so what you're saying is abolish the
government i'm kidding
no but i i certainly hear stories like
this and it definitely makes me
much more of a small government type
person yeah
you know because waste exists in so many
different elements of you know
governmental
function when you just get the money
regardless you don't have
a an incentive to be efficient about it
if you're never going to go bankrupt if
you spend it badly if
if the funding level is never going to
get shut off if you don't have
the right outcomes or achievements
you're going to have less incentive to
spend it wisely or to achieve anything
at all and that's
the problem with yeah well that's what
we see basically in
every government crisis they end up
you know we we have all these states now
that are uh
you know they're locked down their
economy is destroyed their tax base is
gone so what do they do
they go to the federal government they
give us money right and trump said
no and then trump was like actually i'm
gonna take your money away and now
they're freaking out
but it's it's a really interesting uh
problem i think
well i'll keep it at school just for
another minute or two because i wanted
to make i wanted to make the point about
you write about in your book the you
know the college campus stuff
but i kind of feel like you're late to
the party like we all were you know what
i mean yeah
like these kids certainly got these
ideas from somewhere
and i think it's interesting it traces
back to this desire
to actually end racism actually end
sexism and homophobia and things like
that but the way i've always viewed it
is we had you know the previous
generation decided hey wait a minute you
know
these things are bad we should get rid
of them and then we had the civil rights
act for instance
and then we've actually had some you
know other civil rights gains for like
gay marriage and stuff like that
but what happens when the generation
before us
solves those problems but demands their
kids
solve the problems that have already
been solved it's almost like
they've been set on a mission of social
justice
that they don't actually have to solve
anymore you know what i mean
yeah yeah so i guess it's a combination
of things
i think back to when i was a kid in
school and they would tell us these
things like you know
love who you love and be who you are and
racism is bad
and they would tell us these things but
it was really hammered into us
but these things are often already
illegal i don't know i guess
i guess it just ultimately feels like
they've simultaneously created an
ideological drive on accident
while indoctrinating kids to support an
authoritarian
system where they just do what they're
told to do notably
you go to school you have your teacher
you go all the way to college
and you always have someone telling you
exactly what you have to do so what
happens when they get out
couple things for one many of them are
massively in debt
they have no idea how to solve that debt
so they look to the old people and say
what do i do
well the old people at their
universities are lefties and some of
them are communists
probably a lot of them actually and they
say communism is the solution
they're also you know social justice
indoctrinated
so it's like everything we're seeing
right now probably could have been
easily predicted right
although it uh it entertained me how
many of the kind of
activist students were talking about
hold their hard-left professors in utter
contempt
uh because they're their communist
professor they're the old school
left the aclu left right they were like
right but i'm talking right i'm talking
about the former era those people liked
free speech
and they liked an exchange of ideas and
also they were
it was more cla their leftism was class
based not
right and gender and i like that stuff
yes so
the students now i mean those it's those
professors i i i mean i defend
you know conservative speakers when
they're chased off campus conservative
professors but also lots of leftist
professors who are
terrified of their students professors
who are of the left have said
i am terrified of my students even
though probably on policy they mostly
agree
they are terrified they will use the
wrong word the wrong language to
describe particularly relating to race
or gender
oh yeah even though the sentiment is
perfectly in accordance with
progressivism
and there will be there will be an event
there will be a complaint
followed by an investigation into this
um into this uh professor
and uh and it's caused by the woke
students yeah yeah so uh bucko just
jumped on the table yeah we've got a
oh i didn't know if we could acknowledge
that yeah but we can't go no no he's not
there
don't say anything uh did you see that
professor who
said the the chinese words who got
success
is so good oh here it is a chinese word
that sounds like a racial slur
i don't think we can even say the word
because the youtube
filter will pick it up and it'll
translate it as the racial slur
but just to be clear this guy was not
saying a slur he was saying a word in a
different language
that is just a filler word in china like
saying er or
um right right right in chinese okay so
wait wait so here's here's the context
for those that missed this story this is
amazing
so uh robbie wrote the story it's uh usc
suspended a communications professor for
saying a chinese word that sounds like a
racial slur
greg patton was describing the chinese
filler word
it's it's spelled n-e-g-a but i really
am worried because
youtube uses an automatic speech-to-text
filter
and then when they hear they're like
banned
so it's n-e-g-a and you know
some people say it's it's pronounced nay
and then
and you can understand why you know
people would pretend to be angry
but this guy is a communications
professor like he's talking about how to
give a speech and how you would use
different
filler words and depending on different
languages this was a perfectly
appropriate discussion to have so this
is virtual learning
some student was offended he was
reported he was temporarily suspended i
have actually
i don't often receive uh a lot of emails
on a subject that i write about
email just doesn't seem to be the way
people communicate as much these days
sometimes i do it the article goes
really twitter dm
right this this article i have received
a number of emails
from people who were his students uh
some of them who said uh i'm a minority
student
said this this teacher was wonderful he
was great
not a racist bone in his body and they
are outraged by his treatment by us
usc this is a major uh university it's
horrible no
no i'm sorry robby you're wrong he was a
white supremacist
of course he was white well that
explains everything well
that's that's whiteness lock it take me
i'm technically the only non-white
person so both of you you know
i'm a female i apologize you can uh you
robbie you can pay pal me
okay um my paypal is i'm kidding i'm
getting no uh-huh don't pay
this this is really amazing because it's
actually racist to attack him for saying
something in chinese
no but it is yeah like if so so
the general context is we say things
like you know
and like you know like uh when we're
talking about dogs you know that's what
we do
and i i've been saying you know too much
for you know for the past week or so you
said it you said
i'm a like abuser like abuser yeah but
that's what they do
and there's a comedian who has this
really funny bit about it where he said
that he
you know he's in china and there's like
a little kid who walks into a chicken
shop
and there's also like a nigerian woman
and he makes a joke where he says it's
like
the one black person in china or
something and this little kid starts
looking at the menu and he says
you know that word right over and over
and over again and the woman looks at
him and she looks at the guy
and he's like she's looking at me like
i'm supposed to beat this kid up or
something
but the the joke being that i mean it's
not the i'm sure it's not the only
instance
where if you're speaking a different
language you'll hear something that
could be offensive in a different
language
i mean this is the origins of didn't
president kennedy the i am a jelly
doughnut
yeah right yeah it's funny was it
berliner something like that yeah
um i'm a jelly doughnut it's probably
better
for uh for our society for broad racial
tolerance and getting along if we can
all laugh at things like this
and move on i don't know that doesn't
seem like a crazy idea right
look this is funny we can laugh and
that's it this is why
i'm uh look i i think
if if you look at the things i'm talking
about often it's probably very similar
what you're talking about and i consider
myself to be
a social liberal kind of like where
democrats were 10 years ago
you're a libertarian but we're we talk
about a lot of the exact same things
and so do trump supporters and because
of that we all get lumped in as like
right wing but isn't it better to call
out the psychotic
behavior and to do something about it or
or maybe that really is like whatever
the new right is
includes libertarians former liberals
trump supporters
conservatives republicans right and i
guess some democrats who just haven't
realized it yet
well right i mean i i know plenty of
right with the people the kinds of
people i was describing people
who would describe themselves on the
left who are really fed up with this
kind of thing i mean there
there's tons of those sorts of the dirt
bag left the dirtbag left to some extent
um even i would say more mainstream left
people inner there's
glenn greenwald type people um so
they see the harm this has caused i
think to retreat on principles of free
speech from a leftist perspective i
guess they don't feel it as big as a big
as big a threat that uh as i do though
yeah you know because for me it's like
well it is po
well we might disagree then i think it
is possible to over dramatize the threat
as well
i think that i think this is one of the
worst things
it's it's completely illiberal yeah
they're they're shutting down jokes and
what it's doing is it's kind of it's
almost some kind of cultural
balkanization
where you can't wear clothes this is the
cr this is the craziest thing to me
like if if a white person is wearing
clothes that's arguably from some
culture that's not white it's a bad
thing and they get attacked for it
yeah that is bad and to the to the
extent where like we had that
girl going to the prom who had the um
the chinese oh that was
just the worst thing and then you see
that guy who was in china who went on
asking people
and the chinese people are like oh
that's very great like it's very
beautiful like
well that's what's so annoying about
some of this leftist identity politics
stuff is is often it's actually
privileged
wealthy white liberal people who are
purporting to speak
for some oppressed minority even though
the supposedly oppressed minority group
would never be offended by that thing or
most some of them would most people
would not be i mean this is the true
of the latinx thing that that uh white
progressives want you to use but you
couldn't you know you couldn't find two
latino latino people
who actually prefer that right um the
the uh the cato institute which is
libertarian think tank a few years ago
they surveyed
uh minority groups on on how on if you
were offended by certain things that
were
there were supposed to be
microaggressions you know asking where
you're from and a couple other things
yeah and on nearly all of them a
majority of the people who were supposed
to be offended by this thing said they
weren't offended by it
right so then why are we teaching or
training people to be aware
to be aware of this even on i think
there's no scientific basis to it
well there's there's two there's two
main points someone tweeted this what's
the end goal of critical race theory and
someone responded
to leverage white guilt for money and
that's what we see a lot of with these
people like you know
angelo exactly she's and what's funny is
like she's an avowed racist
i i have to bring it up every time
because she's the best she's like a new
york times best seller
her book is like the top of amazon why
why is the left taking their cues from
people who are like
just telling us they're racists well but
she's been she has been tried
the new york times did a long like
takedown of her so did the atlantic
so did yeah a lot of people are saying
man do not
actually take your non-racism cues from
her for sure for sure but
they still are like these viral videos
where there's guilty
again just like exactly what you said
guilty feeling white people are ordering
her book on mass because it's easy to do
that and say okay i did it now i'm now
i'm good i'm one of the good ones
but i i think my my my concern about
this
is for one it's rapidly expanding it's
it's outside
we're all on college campus now yeah why
should i make the assumption that oh
it's just
people you know saying virtue signal and
i'm done
if every month that goes by it expands
and it reaches new heights
because some of these books like the
book from that uh
what was his name ibrahim abraham x
candy yeah where he overtly says we need
discrimination
racial discrimination his big idea is to
create a department of
non-racism or anti-racism or something
that uh but you would require and he he
admits this he wants a
constitutional amendment to create it to
to to void the first amendment
and so this would be a bureaucratic
federal department that would uh
sanction people for expressing racist
views okay okay look this this is as bad
as you can that's as bad as an idea
you know his book is number one in human
rights on amazon yeah and he's had a
like
on the usa today list which tracks
literally just hard sales yeah
he's like number 13 or something so now
it's bad
and he's and he said i think three books
so
look we're all off the campus right now
to me this feels like a serious
existential threat for liberalism
and i don't mean liberalism in the
colloquial american sense i mean
classical liberalism
part of the foundation of this country
individuality consent to the governed
all of these things
he's literally attacking the first
amendment it's not just about this one
guy
yeah it's about going back to 2014
where we all laughed because they were
silly vloggers who were complaining
about you know
inclusivity in games or whatever and now
it's straight up to the point where
10 percent of the cdc staff wrote a
letter demanding
that they declare racism a national
health crisis right if it's if it's
expanding this quickly what in 10 years
then we're literally going to be living
under some like
leftist critical race accuracy where
you know white people oh we can't hire
you because you're white you're
privileged
and you have to give up your property or
something like that or we get to the
point where
heaven like these people have no idea
idea how to address
mixed-race individuals because they
don't know where the privilege falls
so they just make it up do you agree
with me or don't you agree with me
because if you agree with me i'm just
going to say you have privilege and if
you don't agree with me then i'll give
you whatever you want
well and the the first amendment will
will not be abolished be a
constitutional
uh amendment because that's not going to
happen but
the there's the way around it is to
tweak uh harassment law
continuously in a way that just i'm
speaking to the to the hate speech stuff
that i i'm a protected group
so you can't if you've made like this
happen on the campus with
if this is not a a safe educational
environment for me that violates title
ix et cetera
there's the same kind of laws that that
have to do with the workplace
that is the is the next front of kind of
leftists changing
uh how we all live is making so well if
you say something
that offends me even if it's like a boss
giving like totally reasonable feedback
to an employee
well you've made this an unsafe working
environment for me
right but it's worked i think you
mentioned it that it were a compliance
culture
yeah so the new york times claimed that
tom cotton's
op-ed you know sending the troops for
the riots was
making the office unsafe for black
that's exactly what i'm talking about
exploitation of existing law
yeah it's working yep so you're right i
i don't i i'm not worried about that's
my fear
and so you're getting so i this we begin
this by saying you're over dramatizing
it but that is my exact fear yes that is
dangerous but it's going to happen
yes it's already so thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you